please welcome cole sprouse
hello drew i am so excited to talk to
you
for so much i'm excited to talk to you
too i can't believe i've not
met you truly before well and we have
like
an adam sandler in common not to be like
bougie hollywood oh because we both know
him we should know each other what are
your
connections exactly
i know sandler you know sandler
but i i heard you were at his premiere
of uncut gems
i was yeah that was the first time i
really reconnected i mean i reconnected
with him at like some little award show
but uh
he and i he and i reconnected at uncut
gems and we spent
like an hour and a half at the after
party of the premiere just kind of
geeking out about big daddy and what it
was to film that when i was
six now granted i don't remember nearly
as much as he did but he met his wife
on that movie um and so his whole life
kind of went in a very specific
direction from that film
and it was uh i i definitely recall us
having drinks that night or rather don't
recall enough but i know
i was having quite a lot of drinks in
front of him
um and yeah it was just it was really
nice to catch up with him
really nice schedule i i presented him
an award
around that time and i didn't want to
write a speech because i like to speak
off the cuff and from the heart which is
always like more
stomach churning and intimidating but
yeah that's the role of the dice a lot
of people don't make anymore so i'm
impressed with your confidence
thank you it makes me very sick going
into it but i know
that it will be genuine um
and uh i made him tear up which i was
very proud
yeah i also like to watch grown men cry
yes
and adam is just not a big crier so if
you can get to him i was like
good i want you to feel something yeah
making comedians cry is like
it's like there's something arcane about
it you're absolutely right not just men
but
comedians so a male 1 i completely agree
now you took a break from acting
because you wanted to stop and be
educated and you went to nyu
i did yeah after after my brother did
the disney my brother and i did the
disney show we uh
we went to nyu and i took a big break
i never really anticipated i would come
back but i studied
i completed my studies in 2015
yeah 2015 and then got swept back up
into the realm of acting
i love that you studied archaeology i
was reading up a lot on
some of your travels and excavations
yes i uh i traveled all over for it
um i miss it quite a bit still it's
always it's always been that
that profession in the back of my mind
that i imagine i'll eventually return to
um but it was very romantic i mean take
into account
i had spent the previous eight years of
my life before college
uh homeschooled and in a sound stage
there's a tremendous wisdom that comes
from traveling i i
i believe traveling and the privilege of
traveling to be
one of the greatest educations that we
can receive but it is a privilege
and i had studied a i'd studied a
profession that sort of
forced me to grow and learn and and i
think that acting
the the currency of acting is the kind
of empathy that you
that you accrue from traveling and
learning about other people and other
lives and it
seemed honestly in in a strange way
archaeology
and the study of travel became the
greatest acting training that i could
have got as well
i couldn't agree more i love that you
said it's a luxury
because that humility is so important um
but
i do think it is the best education the
more you know about people
in different places the more educated
you are going to be uh
in the most profound and important ways
that you cannot get from study or in a
book
but speaking of travel you
showed up at the desk of conde nast
traveler
and uh-huh and you said
hi i'm cole sprouse can you give me a
gig
yeah pretty much i studied a couple
photography classes when i was in
college
um and i knew that i was going to be
traveling a lot for archaeology so i
started
taking my camera around with me and
conde nast at the but still i think had
a publication named traveler magazine
and i walked into the office with a
button-up shirt and basically said hey
yeah i'll work for free because i'm
traveling i might as well
take some pictures for you guys and i
want to see my stuff in print
um and they said yes and i didn't get
paid
the first couple times as is the classic
tale of the unpaid intern
um in new york i didn't get paid for
like the first
year but then then i got a nice job
you ended up hooking up with yolanda
edwards who's someone
how do you know you love that well i
love your photography
and i have taken photography myself but
i just think
that it's one of the sides of you that i
find so compelling as well as all the
others
and i love i love your photography
and so i wanted to know the origin by
the way i subscribed to yolo journal
i follow her honestly what a life those
cats live
i know and the way they show travel it
hurts
it hurts me yeah tell us a few magazines
that now
have printed your photography
oh man um i think
yeah what is that i i think that's
interview um
now that was a personal shoot um
that was jimmy choo uh collabo
collaboration uh that was
paper uh yes that's sydney sweeney from
euphoria
um that was l magazine um yeah
oh these are fun that was just me taking
pictures of a fog bank crying
very angsty cool that was
montclair in iceland i think your work
is
stunning and i love that you showed up
and
would work for free as an intern to
start uh
your photography journey and it has paid
off for all of us
who get to see it by the way we're gonna
go to commercial break really quickly
uh your nails oh do you like them
yes i do i like them here
i had my roommate in the house painting
because i can't do it i'm not dexterous
enough
uh straight vodka so i
well from men not crying
to men wearing nail polish i'm so in
you